yeah so um thank you everyone um I hope
you can hear me properly my internet
connection I just find out is not
working
properly um so this is um API
development for data
analy or scientist with f
API um just if you have any question or
something uh you can interrupt me is why
uh
so
yes yeah so this is the list of contents
that I am I expect to cover I hope I'll
be able to cover on the testing part if
not um everything is in the in the
GitHub rep so uh we're going to cover uh
just the basic concepts in API
development
were
parameters and
um uh what is a how to connect database
and API authentication but I decided to
just um I just decided lastly in the
last minute to just switch API
authentication and then moving towards
datas um
connection after that just in case I am
not able to cover for iing and yes I
think I'm going to turn the camera off I
think that will help
hopefully um yep I don't know if this is
helpful is it
better yeah well I hope
it's I hope uh you can hear me
quickly hope but there a little
this pleasure here this talk is intended
for non
developers and people
with limited exposure to
supportment so if someone here is from
computer science background or H has
experienc
um a software development just for you
to know I'm going to H say
like I'm going to generalize just for
the
purpose of being more like I
guess people who um are not too familiar
with this so bear that in
mind please
um
yeah um just a little bit about me I I
am a data analyst working Healthcare um
and I am originally from guala I am now
living in well in the UK and I'm very
active active in the Pyon Community
um yes and just
um think some something about my
inter I'm just so
sorry uh it is work fun with me
but yeah don't know this
is you you you don't know till
you um until you you really doing this
sorry about that um and just uh I also
want to say that I am at the moment I am
dealing with the some
um so I hope if you um I'm a it sound
out it would be because of that I'm
doing my best
sorry um yeah let's let's get
started
so well just
like Words uh we can say that an API is
how we
can um communicate doing prr how program
a
talks with program B there should be
like a way or a common language uh for
these two programs intera and this is
where an API is
used so is like Middle
Point um and an API stands for
application
programming interface an
interface basically it it means
something
that um
makes it easier to use you can say it's
a layer on top of some more complex
thing and there are many types of API
there are many types of
prots or language you can say uh but the
most common
is um if you hear about wave web API
it's most likely that um the
architecture behind is rest we're
talking about rest and this is why I'm
focusing on this only in the
um in because it is the thing that you
will most likely work a lot
um so yeah when we talk about
rest we are talking about this
architecture and
arure is a like a set of guidelines on
in this case how to communicate this is
um
done particularly with rest using the
HTTP um protocol so
HTTP um I think you may have heard
before this is
how the internet all the web
is um
communicat built upon that is why rest
apis are all known
as and rest stands
for
representational State
transfer um and yes so I can see there
are
people about my boys I'm sorry let me
just
check um not sure if this is any
better yep
[Music]
um tell me
if all
right can see yes
good that this is
my I'm so sorry um so I was saying that
rest
is very very popular um for API
development and
why the reason why is because it work
over HTTP and HTTP is what we um uh
normally used in widely used widely used
in in in the internet and uh and there
are basically two
main um main Concepts
that's uh we need to know when we're
talking about web
a um which is a request and a response
so request is
basally um a request or asking for a
resource and a resource can
be of data image
whatever and this is done via
URL so for
example if you're working with
um the weather forast for example din
they may be an API
for metet office for example and then
when you want to request the forecast
for London in the next five days then
you you can access that via
URL API so this is a request what
you're asking and what
they what you are uh
getting from that request is what we
called a
response so is basically the content
that um we get and usually we may use in
data scientist or data
analyst you will use or maybe you
perhaps you have already done
that um you will use apis either
for uh requesting or getting new data
from new data sets
or you will also need
to need to build an API in order to for
example to expose your model for other
people to um use your model you have to
um create API and you can do
it fast
API and yeah so just a little bit so for
of us the same uh
um about the same thing this is
um graphical representation
representation of
the when you hear things like clients or
server for example when we when we say
client client
means ER
the someone who is calling your API if
you're buing an API and someone wants to
access your API
that's m is a client when you
access an API you are
the like um
your how like your API your piece of
code that will cod that API will be
declined and the rest API is um stands
in
between right this um is like the
Comm the way between the Communications
of these uh different programs in
this you can see the API or web API
whatever you call
it this stands in the middle between the
database and
the so in this case you can think
of someone who wants to
say I give the list of all the employees
who
salar is above 15
Grands okay so that is a request it is
done not directly to the database that
will be
very um not to uh uh not too smart
really and also improvent for security
issues so that is why we have the API
with our API we can um
we can order
or those um request to the
DAT only
this terms of database it will only be
accessed access access through
one um one one API like
one user uh
quotequote so this is um this is
Bally where the
rest
um is
is um functioning in all
the theit of the the whole application
you're doing and um there you can see
here methods of how this is done I am I
am focusing on this this is important
really
this import for
[Music]
um for when you want to build um secure
apis is is really I'm also dealing with
other
people this is really um is
something useful to know although I
understand that it can be like boring
you it really
really need to um no
this um
so
why fast API I'm very sure you have
heard fast API a lot in the last couple
of I don't know cou years um the fast
API is a we web
framework uh we a web framework for
example that is also very widely
used python it also flask and Jung as
well but
F really is is becoming very very
popular and the reason why is because it
is extremely um fast that
is hence the name is really fast and it
is very very popular and I think it's
yeah according
to the
umy behind it it
is apparently the third most
used and loved framework in Python and
is really really comparable the
execution compar with um for example of
a go with some
um and yeah programs in
go really really good um
is the reason why it
is like a lot of has a lot of
popular it is that means that is as well
the community is
grow for API that means that a very safe
choice for something to learn and
something that you may consider
Implement yourself um so I really
recommend it if you want to use if you
want
to build an API
consider fast API um because really is
um is a safe Choice Microsoft is using
it um I
think Facebook as well perhaps I'm sure
Microsoft for sure using Google as well
yeah another thing is that is based on
standards meaning that uh
be fast API there are a lot of uh
standards
and meaning it is uh it helps
you to stay on you know good standards
and save a little bit of work so really
with fast API you don't have to worry
about like
uming B you know all this stuff mostly
with set commands mostly you'll be um
having all this extra work
or for you so is not complicated at all
I find it very simple
and the thing that I love the most about
fast AP is the documentations I
think it is the best doation
I um so really if you if
you question or something go to
the page yeah it is really really simple
to use and
um yeah that that's why fast
API my uh safe choice for
building apis before fast AP I was using
flask or something like really simple
and minimal stuff now fast
API chice so um what I was saying about
the
different methods I was say first I
don't if I
was if you
hear properly because of the audio
issues I was saying that
um
API Al known as web
apis they um they run over HTTP and
HTTP they have some methods and these
are um used
like you can use this on your
AI the for example there are many
more but these are some very ESP are the
first two um so a get method is a
method over HTTP
that um is used when you want to read or
like request a
resource you have you have you seen
before for example when
you access I don't know
HTTP um and Google
do whatever you misspell
something and then you may find
44 ever this means
that uh there you made a request
you as the client you made a request to
AO um and that could not PR or it was
like not found that is what you do with
your API as well uh you want to do that
but without you know the um contary to
do like for example a web
application a a web API it doesn't
have a like a
g you know it's it only retrieves uh
data without the
graphic website that is only what you
like the back end your AI could work for
it's part of the back end um
so yeah question yes please
um um so another
method is post
that c a resource and and
delete
um is almost over
oh I can believe um so this is you can
see here fast API like the H world of
fast API look at how many lines of code
there you import here fast API really
and you can install it with P of fast
API and you initiate the app um this is
basically a fast API
API and this what you're see here you're
finding a
root or the end point where the user
will access your API
and this this is
saying when user goes to the domain for
example
domain SL then ex this function and this
function takes
no um and it's also using the get method
get me and it's not and not not
receiving anything no parameters but is
ruring a message this
this in Python is automatically
converted Jon uh this is part of have to
worry about that everything is
automatically by default um return to
Jason so this is very simple you can see
and but you may
want to receive from your client you may
want to receive some information for
example um for example in the
forecast um example
H when I want say for
example I want to
request all the forecast for London in
the next five days then I have in my
have
something to this and I for example this
saying items
slash and this between these
two
this means that it's going to receive
something this something is here we're
saying it is integer and um it will
be what I'm going to return can be
something string or
nothing um so this is here B I return
this of
course um have you know this is where
you can put some
your you commun with your database you
ask that question you
retrieve everything here you will
retrieve uh is
basically how you can get some
information from the
client and then use it in your
fun to
something and authentication have you uh
find some for example when you uh log
Google you you sometimes you have to you
have to put your email and password
right so behind that there is there is a
sort of there's a way of authentication
you can do exactly the same your own
apis because you don't want
to just leave your API open for everyone
to uh to consume it no
uh you have to
limit uh for security purp you you you
want to limit your the access of your
you can do it in different different
ways this is one way to do it and with
API keys look as
well it doesn't take many
many of cod this only here
you you can store obviously this is
for um just for example
purposes but you want to uh save your
API
keys in your database or in
environment uh
viable yeah you have
your here you H this is a function where
you're saying is the API the the API
that
um I
IED is it here
con and if yes then you proceed if not
you
return an error then this is your API
this is really your what the user is
going
to the user is going to access this
URL and then you do some here and you
return the answer after validating this
this is real as well how are you going
to consume it if you want to consume
this and from
another and when you
access um fast API if you use fast
API it's really really very easy to
test locally because uh what you're
seeing
here is um all the documentation
generated automatically for you um and
this is something really nice